we've been trying to figure out the real
reason for Donald Trump firing FBI
director James Comey yesterday and
there's a separate sort of parallel
story to this that is really really
important which is that we've learned
through a report by CNN that federal
prosecutors have issued grand jury
subpoenas to Associates a former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
looking for business records in relation
to Russian involvement in the
presidential election this is becoming
more and more serious CNN learned about
these subpoenas here we go now hours
before President Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey the subpoenas may
not sound like much but this is a real
escalation of the FBI investigation of
the Senate investigation of the
investigation apparatus that exists here
what will happen now as a result of the
firing of James Comey we know call me
will no longer be testifying tomorrow
but the subpoenas have been issued
investigators have been looking into
possible wrongdoing in how Flynn handled
disclosures about payments from clients
tied to foreign government this includes
Russia this includes Turkey
congressional investigators have also
accused Flynn of possibly having broken
the law by not disclosing those tens of
thousands of dollars in monies that he
received for his appearance in Moscow at
a Russia today RT television celebration
how will the upcoming season of house of
cards compared to real life at this
point house of cards is more believable
than what's going on but it's all too
real it honestly is I mean I don't think
they can top what's going on here and
remember about a month or two ago when
Joaquin Castro who's on the House
Intelligence Committee yep said that he
predicted some Trump aides would end up
being behind bars as a result of this
yes I think Michael Flynn was the guy
that he was thinking about or Flynn's
aides who also have been subpoenaed but
yes I think you're we're getting closer
and closer to figuring that out more
people may be fired here if Trump says
he has full confidence in someone look
for that person to be fired within a
couple of weeks because now there's
multiple people that Trump had full
confidence in that have even either
resigned or been forced to resign or
been fired
reporter Claude Taylor has been
reporting about the
for a week cNN has now corroborated it
Claude Taylor is now reporting that
there are nine indictments already ready
to go he tweeted yesterday a source with
knowledge of the investigation says that
nine sealed indictments came down in one
case with 16 more expected in others
obviously this has not been
independently verified but Claude Taylor
has been right about a lot so far isn't
it hugely disturbing that increasingly
the people in charge of various
investigations into Trump Russia are
puppets of the president if I were North
Korea right now I'd be worried because
when this sort of thing starts to go
down presidents want distractions and
there's no better distraction than
sending some missiles to North Korea if
you're Donald Trump it certainly is and
when you have Devin Nunez who at one
point was in charge of the House
Intelligence Committee and then you have
now FBI director who got fired because
Trump wasn't happy with his performance
who knows who he's going to replace him
with it just undermines the credibility
completely yeah but Pat I mean it's
really hard for me to see any ties
between Trump and Russia I mean all
you've got is the Paul Manafort Fiasco
and the Michael Flynn Fiasco and the
Jeff Sessions Russia lies and Jared
Kushner's dozens of undisclosed meetings
with Russian officials and the Carter
page thing and the Eric Trump and Donald
turn junior statements contradicting
Donald Trump's claims that they don't
have any business with Russia by
admitting they have plenty of business
with Russia and Trump's public requests
for Russia to hack Hillary Clinton's
emails and the Russian blackmail dossier
research from former British
intelligence agent Christopher Steele
attempting to prevent Sally Yates from
testifying about Russia
Devin Nunez running to the White House
to tell Trump what the Russia
investigation had going on the meetings
involving Felix Seder other than that
and about 20 other things
there's no connections between Trump and
Russia right and aside from all those
things there's nothing there and I think
it's one thing when progresses say that
we shouldn't put all of our eggs into
one basket when it comes to the Trump
Russia investigation and maybe we should
focus more on the policies and how a
Republicans are trying to destroy the
country yeah but to suggest that there's
nothing there
belies gradually at this point send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show